Welcome back.
So we're on problem number 5.
In the schedule above,
each session is to be
an hour and a half.
Each break is to be 1/4 hour.
And lunch is to be
1 hour long.
If Session IV is to end at 4:30
PM, at what time should
Session I begin?
So there's actually
two ways to do it.
When I just glanced at this, I
said, well, I'll just fill in
this chart.
And actually, I'm going to do
that as well, just to show you
that they get the same answer.
But there is a faster way
to do this problem.
Essentially, what they're saying
is the day ends at
4:30, right?
Because 4:30 is the last thing
that happens in the day.
And then they're saying, what
time should Session I begin?
So they're essentially
saying, what time
should the day begin?
So if we can just figure out
how many hours are in this
day, and then take that many
hours from 4:30 PM, we would
get our answer for when Session
1 should begin.
So how many hours
are in the day?
Well, there's one, two,
three, four sessions.
4 sessions times an hour
and a half each.
Well, 4 times 1 and 1/2,
that's 6 hours.
You can multiply the fractions
if you don't believe me.
6 hours.
There's 1 lunch.
1 lunch is 1 hour.
And then how many breaks
are there?
There's 2 breaks.
So there's 2 breaks times 1/4.
So that equals 1/2.
So if we were to add up the
hours for the sessions, the
lunch and the breaks, we would
get 7 and 1/2 hours.
And so then you just have to
figure out, well, what is 7
and 1/2 hours before 4:30 PM?
Sometimes people get
uncomfortable subtracting time
past noon, because it
gets a little weird.
So the way I think about
it, break it up.
Well, if I go 4 and 1/2 hours
ago, if I go from 4:30 and I
go minus 4 and 1/2 hours, then
I get to noon, right?
And so we already took
out 4 and 1/2 hours.
And we want to take out 7 and
1/2, so we have 3 hours left
to take out.
So 12-- you take out 3
hours, well, that's
easy, that's 9:00 AM.
And so that would
be our answer.
That's the fast way to do it.
Actually, it might not be the
fast way, because you'd have
to think about all of these
things, and you're not sure if
you subtracted right.
The other option is
just fill it in.
This session ends at 4:30, so
it has to begin at 4:00.
Or no, sorry, it has to
begin at 3:00, right?
Hour and a half.
So that means this break would
have to end at 3 o'clock, and
begin at 2:45.
This would have had to end at
2:45, and begin at 1:15.
This would have to end at
1:15, begin at 12:15.
End at 12:15, if you go an hour
and a half before 12:15,
2 hours would be 10:15,
so it would be 10:45.
This ends at 10:45, and so it's
a 15-minute break, so it
would have to start at 10:30.
And then if this ends at 10:30,
and you subtract an
hour and a half from that, you
get to 9:00 AM, which is our
answer either way.
So the second way, filling it
out, actually isn't that bad.
If that immediately is what
comes to you, it still didn't
take too much time.
You could have done it
that way as well.
Move on to the next problem.
Number 6.
I will change colors.
If 2x minus 5, x plus 1, and 3x
minus 8 are all integers,
and x plus 1 is the median
of these integers.
So this is the median.
Now, what does median mean?
Median just means the middle
number, right?
If I have a bunch of numbers--
if I have 1, 3, 7, 8, 9.
The middle number here,
it's not the average.
It's just what number-- half
the numbers are larger, and
half the numbers are smaller.
So in this example, the middle
number would be 7.
So that's all median means.
So it's telling us that x plus
1 is the median number.
They say, which of the
following could
be a value for x?
And they give a bunch
of choices.
In this type of situation, I
just try them out, because
these are pretty straightforward
equations.
They're giving us pretty
clean numbers.
Let's just try it out.
Choice A.
So 2x minus 5 is 2
times 5 minus 5.
That's 10 minus 5.
That equals 5.
x plus 1 is 5 plus 1,
which equals 6.
And this is the x plus 1 term,
so it should be our median.
And then 3 times 5 minus 8.
3 times 5 minus 8, well,
that's 15 minus
8 is equal to 7.
Well, we lucked out.
Looks like the x plus 1
term was the median.
And that's probably a good
indication that they wanted us
to try out the numbers, because
they actually gave the
first choice as being the
one that worked out.
So the choice is A.
Move on.
I'll try a different method
of deleting things.
Look at that.
That was pretty neat.
So now we're on number 7.
An exhibitor is selling
decorative wreaths at an arts
and craft show.
Useless sentence.
The net profit p in dollars from
the sales of the wreath
is given by-- now, this is a
useful piece of information.
p of n is equal to 0.75n minus
50, where n is the number of
wreaths sold.
How many wreaths must the
exhibitor sell in order to
earn a net profit of $100?
Well, we want this thing
to equal $100, right?
So we just set it
equal to 100.
100 is equal to 0.75n
minus 50.
Add 50 to both sides.
150 is equal to 0.75n.
And I like to write-- I like
to deal with fractions.
I don't not like decimals,
but fractions are easier.
This is the same
thing as 3/4 n.
0.75 is the same thing as 3/4.
So now we just multiply both
sides times-- something was
ringing in my computer, but
anyway-- multiply both sides
times the inverse of this
coefficient, so times 4/3.
This of course cancels, so we
just have n left on the
right-hand side.
And on this side,
4/3 times 150/1.
The 150 cancels out
with the 3.
This becomes 1.
So 4 times 50 is 200.
You just have a 1 in
the denominator.
Is equal to n.
There you go.
The exhibitor has to sell 200
wreaths, which is choice E.
Next problem, number 8, which
I will do in yellow.
If x squared plus y squared is
equal to 73, and xy is equal
to 24, what is x
plus y squared?
What happens when you multiply
x plus y squared?
x plus y squared is the
same thing as x plus y
times x plus y.
And this might be second nature
to you after taking a
lot of algebra, but I'll
just multiply it out
just to show you.
x times x is x squared.
x times y is xy.
y times x is xy.
And then y times
y is y squared.
So it equals x squared plus
2xy plus y squared.
Well, that's interesting.
We know that these two terms
combined, that's x squared
plus y squared.
So we know that that
equals 73.
I know I'm running out of--
let me write it up here.
So x squared plus 2xy
6 plus y squared.
So these two terms are 73.
So we have 73 plus-- and we
can cancel those two out.
And then we have 2xy.
Well, we know xy
is equal to 24.
So it's 2 times 24.
So it's 73 plus 48.
And then, let's see.
7-- I think this is going
to be what, 121?
If my math is not-- let's see.
7, so it's 110, plus
another 11.
Right.
121.
That's all there was.
You just really have to expand
out x plus y squared, and then
you say, oh, well, they kind of
give you what the component
terms, what the values are,
and then we're done.
I'll see you in the
next video.